Speaker 1: Well, according to new reports, the
new evidence that the January six committee has
received, mostly, of course, through
this Alex Holder documentary footage.
Is so intense and so overwhelming that
they have now decided to postpone.
The remainder of their televised hearings so that
they can digest all of this new information, all
of this new evidence. They're calling it evidence,
not just information. This is evidence, folks. The
use of that word, of course, legally speaking,
implies that there is something there, something
there that the committee needs, something there
that the committee can use. To possibly go after
more leads, go after more people, call more
witnesses, find new paths which to investigate.
They're not postponing these hearings lightly
either. They didn't just look at and say, okay,
we're going to push all this back. No,
no, no, no. They understand how powerful
these hearings have been, right? They know
that the public is watching them. They know
that it is affecting public opinion. Donald
Trump's unfavorability ratings have gone up
since these hearings began. More people say that,
yes, he was involved. Yes, he should be criminally
charged. That poll has basically flipped since
these hearings began. So by postponing them,
the committee is taking a big risk, but they
believe the risk will be worth the reward.
And that, of course, is based on the information
they have seen thus far from that documentary
footage. So it's got to be something good. It's
got to be more than just a vodka contradicting
herself, possibly lying under oath to the
committee. There's got to be much more than
that. For them to push these hearings back. Couple
days, couple weeks. We don't even really know yet.
But when they come back, they're going
to show us what's in this footage.
And I'm expecting some pretty big fireworks.
We have to take a quick break again. I am
Ferron cousins. You can find me on YouTube
at YouTube.com, slash the ring of fire
and YouTube.com slash fair and balanced.
And I'm across all social media, Twitter,
Instagram and Facebook at Fair and Balanced. This
is the David Pakman show. And we'll be right back.